[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with economist at
the article ali muraj and alison morris
columnist at the belfast telegraph
they'll be both with us from now until
just before midnight so let's see what's
on some of those front pages now
according to the financial times boris
johnson will next week offer pay rises
averaging around five percent to
millions of public sector workers
the front page of the times leads with a
report about rishi sunak accusing his
conservative party leadership opponents
penny mordant and liz truss of being
irresponsible and dishonest about tax
cuts
liz tax boost four families the daily
mail leads with a report that families
would be offered a tax break of up to
2500 pounds under plans being considered
by liz truss
on the front of the telegraph a report
that candidate penny mordant insists her
record in government shows she is ready
to become prime minister
the express leads with a message from
boris johnson that whoever becomes the
next prime minister must finish the job
on brexit
the front of the guardian focuses on the
rising temperatures reporting a warning
from an expert that thousands of people
could die in the coming heat wave
meltdown is the headline on the mirror's
front page leading with the met office's
first ever red heat warning
the eye also leads on the hot weather
reporting on the national emergency
declared after the uk's first red
extreme heat warning
and the front page of the daily star
contains a report that warmer weather
could soon bring great white sharks to
britain
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by ali mirage
and alison morris welcome to you both
good to see you let's start with the the
eye and the weather 40 degree alert ali
yes it's uh it's serious uh jillian and
uh clearly the uh the met office issued
a
red alert uh this is uh serious and
unprecedented uh and people should take
great care particularly the very young
and the elderly who are more vulnerable
to extreme heat but even able-bodied fit
people need to be careful we have to be
mindful of how much time we spend
during the day outside the peak of the
heat
and take things a little bit more slowly
and make sure that we're well hydrated
but
there's a deeper issue as well here
which is
uh what do we do about our
decarbonization pathway uh there's been
a lot of talk about even the tory
leadership which we may come to about
net zero targets and 2050 and all this
sort of stuff and you know that um last
year we saw these big flash floods in
greece uh sorry uh fires in greece we
saw flash floods in
belgium and the netherlands leading to
loss of life uh and this could
potentially be here
to come now i mean this is like here to
stay and then we've got to also look at
the resilience of our national
infrastructure in this we've got railway
lines potentially going to be buckling
uh in the heat so there are serious
problems to consider and that all is
against the backdrop of the moment
of an energy security crisis where
unfortunately it looks like some of our
decarbonization targets will have to be
uh subdued whilst we deal with a more
immediate problem of keeping the lights
on
uh this is uh certainly evidence for the
the climate change douses alison isn't
it i mean we're hearing that this would
be the first time that we would actually
have this warning at this level first
time ever record-breaking temperatures
of 40 degrees
plus potentially
yeah and i mean it's if we needed more
evidence you know as ali said in the
past few years we've seen examples of
really extreme weather all over the
world and the problems that that causes
you know specifically two people who
live um near coast specifically the
people who live on land which is
susceptible to flooding or to extreme
heat um and while you know i've worked
in newspapers for over 20 years and i
guarantee you there'll be lots of
pictures inside the the tabloids of you
know people sunbathing and um you know
trying to keep cool and barbecuing and
making it all look great fun but it's
it's dangerous it's dangerous for babies
it's doing just for elderly people i
really feel for anyone who has to work
outside and that kind of heat in um
northern ireland we've had a very irish
summer it's basically rained for most of
the the summer here but we're saying
that there's going to be you know
temperatures of 30 degrees which is
slightly cooler but still very
uncomfortable um so yeah i mean i do
think that with the warnings are there
and interestingly you know as part of
the the tory leadership we're hearing
people you know some of the candidates
talking about stepping back from a lot
of those sort of green environmental
issues and removing the obligations on
businesses and the green tax levy and
all sorts of other things so you wonder
how seriously you know where the
politicians actually taking this
yes and we have to look at some of the
the the mitigation that's uh being put
in place ally uh some schools to close
early um
also hospitals starting to to cancel
some surgeries
well look i think the schools thing is
uh very sensible these are precautions
that just seem like the right thing to
do on hospitals uh jillian we've already
got real problems right now
uh in hospital got 6.5 million waiting
lists you've just seen in the last 24
hours a lot of reporting
about the ambulance situation here with
ambulances waiting up to 11 hours
uh with patients uh inside them because
they can't be admitted to a e because
there are no space the beds are blocked
up and that's because
people can't exit into social care much
of the time
and therefore they are bed blocking in
in hospitals and that's causing a
knock-on effect uh leading to people who
are in in the case of even heart attacks
not being getting an ambulance for over
50 minutes when it should be there
within under 20. so
serious problems no easy answers i think
the government to be fair has tried to
increase that uh
national insurance
social care levy
it's not going to raise as much as we
hoped because they've increased the
national
insurance tax thresholds but look none
of this is easy and this all requires
investment in the meantime we've got
this heat now a lot of us enjoy the heat
and that's great uh but we need to be
careful but i do think on the other side
of the equation it will probably give a
boost as long as people act sensibly uh
to the hospitality industry to people
taking uh holidays in the uk uh and
whilst you you know you should sit under
uh natural shade it'd be nice to put on
a few tunes in the back garden and no
need to go to ibiza this summer
the mirror their headline just one word
meltdown
41 degrees scorcher set to close roads
and and stop trains uh allison i wonder
if you you feel that that uh preparation
hasn't been made for for this
eventuality we we know that uh the
planet's getting hotter
just to say i do my best to help the
hospitality industry all year round i
don't just wait until the weather's good
um we just don't have the infrastructure
for it because the temperatures have
never been that high before so you know
just like when you go to companies that
are very warm if there's torrential rain
you can see that their infrastructure
isn't really prepared for extreme
weather we're not prepared for extreme
heat and you know many of the as you
said about you know train lines buckling
and all sorts of other things and that
that is always going to be a problem
because it's just something that is so
unprecedented and if temperatures are
going to continue to get higher they are
going to have to look at putting other
kinds of mitigations in place to try and
protect people during the summer months
from this kind of extreme heat um as
well as obviously taking climate change
far more seriously and accepted that
we're in a climate change um emergency
right now
and this is the world that we're leaving
our children doing hurt and something
has to be done to stop temperatures
rising in this way just to reiterate it
it must be taken seriously the uk health
security agency warns that illness and
death may occur so um it isn't it isn't
beach weather if people are thinking
that it is um let's move on to the ft
um and this is the public sector staff
in five percent pay offer this to be uh
brought in by boris johnson uh although
he wasn't supposed to be making any
policies uh uh before he actually left
office ali
well indeed are you surprised that he's
not keeping to his word uh look this is
going to cost 7 billion and it looks
like it may not be enough i mean you've
got unite the union now
saying that it's going to be
engaging in strike action potentially
over the summer you've got as left the
train drivers union also doing it at the
rmt uh teachers are also wanting
an inflationary pay rise and look it's a
very very difficult situation that the
country faces right now you've got
inflation currently at nine percent
heading towards double digits uh andrew
bailey the governor of the bank of
england saying that he's largely
not not completely helpless but there's
a limited amount that they can do i do
think the bank of england now needs to
step up as mervyn king the previous
governor of bank of england said and
start doing what it can do which is
raise interest rates which is also
pretty unpalatable given where we are in
terms of cost of living issues but
the the issue with inflationary pay
rises this is not inflationary but it's
uh it's on the way it's five percent uh
is that they
add to this problem of inflation and
take it longer to get out of the system
now
obviously
that is little comfort to people who are
really struggling and i think the deeper
here uh the deeper issue here julian is
the fact that
the capitalist system
uh that we know and love and i'm a big
proponent of it is not working for
everyone and it hasn't been working for
everyone for the last two decades people
have had at the lower end of the income
spectrum have had falling real wages for
up to two decades now and they've had
enough and what you've been seeing here
is since the last financial crisis in
2007 when austerity came in a lot of
people haven't seen their standard
living increasing and now with inflation
rampant where it is
this is causing real problems so you can
fully understand why people are
campaigning for this and also why
there's not been a big backlash against
people asking for these kind of pay
rises look i think we need to be
cautious on it but i understand exactly
the sentiment that's driving it
uh and alison do you think this five
percent payoff is going to be enough to
to avert uh you know months of strikes
potential strikes
well when it's been estimated that
inflation could be as high as 11 percent
you know by the by the autumn or winter
and you think about the stress on people
who many of wh the sort of staff were
talking about those public sector
workers are not highly paid staff you
know they're people on low to medium
incomes and we all know we can all see
the difference in our you know our
purses and our our household budgets
because of the cost of living crisis so
five percent and 11 percent increase
isn't a lot the issue is you know as ali
said it has to be paid for from
somewhere it has to come from somewhere
it's interesting boris johnson is going
to do this before he leaves office and
then leave it for someone else to work
out how to pay for it but um the fact is
that then you have you know people who
are trying to be the next story later
talking about cutting taxes cutting
about you know cutting um reversing the
sort of national insurance psych and all
those sort of things and yet how are we
going to pay for this the fact is people
deserve to be able to be properly paid
for their work and not to have to you
know we have situations which nurses
rely on food banks after working 12-hour
shifts they think that's just
unacceptable so there has to be a pay
increase increase across the public
sector because the cost of living has
increased so much you know people in the
private sector are campaigning for pay
raises it's just right that the public
sector should receive them as well is
five percent going to be enough no i
don't think it is going to be enough but
at the same time too i think that the
unions have to negotiate in good faith
and i think that the government also has
to negotiate in good faith
interesting as you say who will be uh
the next uh bod to uh sort out how it's
all paid for uh alison and ali for the
moment thank you you're gonna take a
break and coming up boys johnson's
message to the next prime minister to
finish the job on brexit
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me alone raj and
alison morris welcome back to both of
you let us have a look at the uh daily
express ally um and uh they're
suggesting that boris johnson says his
successor must finish the brexit job and
protect his legacy on ukraine that's his
message to his successor and it goes on
and says he will keep a bdi
well indeed because he's made such a
cat-handed job of completing the job
himself
i mean you look at the issues we've got
on the northern ireland protocol where
the government's now trying to play
hardball with the eu and bringing in
legislation in parliament to try and
deal with all the issues around this
protocol which would have been easily
foreseen before i mean the whole entire
negotiation was built around the fact
there had to be a border somewhere and
that border was going to be in the irish
sea and uh the government basically
threw the dup the democrat ultra unions
party uh under the bus and and now
obviously power sharing is not working
so all has to be revisited and the
government's coming up with this new
strategy and against uh the uh the
wishes of the eu and it's gonna cause a
potentially a trade war in due course so
which i hope it doesn't but but that's
where it may end up on the ukraine issue
look i think boris johnson wanted a lot
of plaudits for leading the way on
ukraine that's all very commendable but
where i think
he also needs to be honest with people
and hasn't been is the massive economic
cost
it is going to entail for this country
i'm not saying that we shouldn't entail
that cost but people need to be
transparent with the public i mean we
are in economic war with russia now
cutting gas supplies uh to germany uh
admittedly for 10 days might last a lot
longer our energy prices could be high
not for months for years to come putin
has got absolutely zero incentive to
make life easy particularly with
economic sanctions i think if that's
where we're going we just need to be
honest about it that this pain is going
to continue and the government cannot
insulate everyone uh from the effects of
that alison there quickly your views are
on uh boris johnson's advice to the next
pm on on brexit in particular
well it's it's really important to
northern ireland we have no functioning
government at present the dep are
refusing to go back into government so
they'll be hoping for someone like liz
trust who's going to push ahead with the
protocol bill which is incredibly
controversial and website large large um
aspects of of the agreement with the eu
rather than maybe someone like grisham's
a trade inaudible but all of this you
know has been watched very closely on
you know of the side of the rhe because
what happens with an xpm in terms of the
protocol is crucial to her you know
things progress here both in terms of
trade because of brexit but also in
terms of how our government functions
uh just uh very quickly i'll run the
viewers through our front pages on the
tory uh leadership contest the telegraph
morden insists she's up to the job we're
going to talk about that a little bit
more uh the mail list tax boost for
families and uh the time soon ax plea
for honesty uh some might say it's a
little bit uh late but ali and uh alison
thank you very much for taking us
through the papers we